i'm not really sure what magnus wants to
do here though because okay he just
pushes the pawn this is what ivanka was
mentioning earlier so two reasons for
that one to create an escape square for
the white king later on just in case and
secondly also to limit black's light
squared bishop so black's light square
bishop can't come now to that right side
and harass any white knights i have to
say one thing now that night on the
second row is tied down to the defense
of its sibling because uh once that
night steps away then there's always
moves like bishop takes pawn undermining
the defense of the knight in the air
yeah so you think these two knights they
need to maintain contact defend each
other because if the knight does move
away um for example if black just makes
a move if the white knight moves away
then as you mentioned your banker bishop
takes pawn and now this pawn is
overloaded it needs to defend its own
knight but now if it takes the bishop
then that knight falls so black would
have won a pawn in the process also just
very thematically maybe even stronger
than bishop takes pawn which just wins
upon maybe you can go for a direct
attack if black ever gets the
opportunity to sacrifice a rook for a
night look at the white king now
suddenly out into the open is about to
get checked it's about to get attacked
black bishop could jump in black's queen
will deliver a killing blow i think and
this king is doomed so yeah as ivanka
mentioned right now no matter what black
does this night
this knight needs to protect its fellow
knight